Hello everyone,
my name is Kinsey
Kornick and I am one
of the family medicine
physicians on the
Jonesboro campus.
I will be giving you
our lecture on clinical
dermatology today where we
will talk about how to take
a history and exam for
dermatologic complaints.
Our objectives
are listed here. A
full of notes before we start.
Reaching a final diagnosis
for a dermatological
complaint can be difficult,
but if you know how to
properly use the terminology
that you will learn in this
lecture to describe
lesions you will be more
successful in identifying
differential diagnoses and how
to evaluate them further
I have included photos of
skin lesions across a
range of skin tones however
to keep this presentation
manageable I couldn't
provide an image of each
lesion on every skin color for
additional examples of how
skin lesions present on
various skin tones I encourage
you to utilize visual
diagnosis which we have
access through the library
and other resources that
are listed in your CPG.
All right, moving on to
you have a patient that
is presenting with a
dermatological complaint.
Before even walking
into the exam room,
take into account
what you already know.
The patient's
age, their gender,
their ethnicity,
their vital signs. Do
they have abnormal vital
signs? Does that fit,
especially if it's an acute
presentation of whatever
their chief complaint is.
Is the chief complaint a
rash, a single skin lesion,
a lump,
hair loss, hair growth?
Differentiating whether
a chief complaint
is acute or chronic
will help to
narrow your differential
substantially.
If it's chronic,
has it been present
for three months, six
months? How has it
changed over that time?
Has it been present that entire
time frame? Has
it been episodic?
Did it come on suddenly, or
was the onset more gradual?
Distinguishing what
parts of the body are
affected by a rash or
skin lesion will also be
very revealing as to
what the causes might be.
Is the rash generalized
or diffuse over the
entirety of the body or
the majority of the body?
Is it only affecting
one side of the body?
Is it occurring on sun-exposed
skin, which we consider
the head, ears, face,
neck, forearms, and hands?
These are also referred to
as photosensitive areas.
Does it occur on the trunk, the
chest, the back, the abdomen?
Does the rash or skin
lesion affect the extremity?
If it does, what part
of the extremities? The
acral portion of the
extremities is the distal
aspect. The extensor
surfaces are considered the
posterior arm and forearm,
the anterior thigh
and leg, or the flexural
or flexor surfaces such
as the antecubital fossa
or popliteal fossa.
Whether or not a rash
or skin lesion affects
the palms and soles
can also be a key
distinguishing feature
in determining whether
a certain diagnosis
is possible or not?
Does it affect the
intertriginous areas
or areas where two
skin surfaces meet,
such as the axilla or
the inguinal region?
Does it affect the web spaces
between the fingers and toes?
Are mucosal surfaces affected?
If the rash involves
the scalp or other areas
of hair growth, what
does that indicate?
Oh, has the chief complaint
changed over time
or progressed?
Has it been constant
or intermittent?
If it's intermittent,
when does it happen?
Does it happen at a
certain time of the day or
only in association with
a specific activity?
Did it start in one area and
spread to the other areas?
We refer to some of these
more specifically in terms
of a spread. So centrifugal
spread is a rash that
started on the trunk and
spread to the extremities.
Centripetal spread is
a rash that started
on the extremities and
spread to the trunk.
Cephalic to caudal
spread or cephalocaudal
spread is a rash
that started on the
head and spread down
towards the feet.
Did anything precede
or trigger this rash
or skin lesion? Was
there recent travel?
Were they hiking outdoors?
Did they encountered different
animals than they
normally would?
Do they remember
any insect bites?
Sun exposure.
Did the sun exposure
exacerbate another
condition or was it the
trigger in and of itself?
Does anybody else have
a similar rash? You
usually ask this by
asking, does anyone you
share a living space
with have a similar rash?
Other questions to ask
that might be a little
bit more specific to a
dermatologic complaint
are things like, have
you tried a new laundry
detergent? Have you
bought new clothing?
Has there been any new
shampoo or lotion, body
wash or other items that
you apply to your skin?
What do they do for
work? Do they have
an occupational
exposure of some type?
Do they have contact with
certain chemicals or is
there airborne exposures
that they wear PPE for?
Did the place they work
just change the hand
sanitizer or the type
of soap they use. Let's
take a minute and talk
about associated symptoms.
So associated
symptoms are different
than your review of systems.
Associated symptoms
are signs and symptoms
that help you differentiate
between the most
likely diagnoses for
the chief complaint.
Associated symptoms
are signs and symptoms
that can also indicate
severity or progression
of the diagnoses for
the chief complaint.
Is the rash itchy,
painful or numb?
Have they had any fever,
fatigue, or joint pain?
How to acquire a past
medical history has already
been taught to you. The
lecture Dermatologic
Signs of Systemic Disease
will expand on when past
medical history can be
relevant to a dermatologic
chief complaint, so I
will move on from here.
Now how do we describe
what you see and feel?
First, you have to
touch the patient.
Palpation is necessary to fully
describe what a
rash or lesion is.
Primary and secondary
skin lesions are the most
important concept to take
away from this lecture.
A primary skin lesion is
the physical change in
the skin caused directly
by the disease process.
A secondary skin lesion
can evolve from that
primary lesion or may be
caused by external forces
on that primary skin
lesion. Those forces can
be scratching, trauma,
infection, or healing.
Now let's go through the
primary skin lesions. One of
the first steps in
differentiating these skin lesions
is whether or not they are
palpable or not palpable.
If a lesion is
palpable, that generally
means that it is elevated
or raised, but it
can also be depressed.
As long as you are
able to feel it, it is
considered palpable.
The non-palpable lesions
are a macule or a patch.
A macule comes from the Latin
word macula, meaning spot.
It is a circumscribed area
less than one centimeter
in size that is flat and
level with the skin surface
and differs only in color
from the surrounding skin.
A patch is a
circumscribed area that is
greater than one
centimeter that is also
flat level with the
skin surface and differs
only in color from
the surrounding skin.
So again macules and
patches are non palpable.
The remaining lesions
are all palpable lesions.
We start with a papule
which comes from the
Latin word papula meaning
pimple. It is a solid
circumscribed lesion less
than one centimeter in
size that is elevated
above the skin surface.
A nodule comes from
the Latin word nodulus,
meaning small knot, and
is a solid circumscribed
lesion that is one to
five centimeters in
size and is elevated
above the skin surface.
A tumor is a solid
circumscribed mass
greater than five
centimeters that
is elevated above
the skin surface.
moving on to the next
primary skin lesions we have
a plaque which comes from
the french word for plate
plaques are solid circumscribed
lesions greater than
one centimeter in size
that are broadly elevated
vesicles and boule are fluid
filled lesions a vesicle
comes from a Latin word
vesicula, meaning little
bladder, and is an elevated
circumscribed serous
fluid-filled lesion less
than one centimeter in size.
Bule comes from the Latin
word bula, meaning bubble,
and is an elevated
circumscribed serous fluid
-filled lesion greater than
one centimeter in size.
Other terms that you'll
see associated with
bule is whether they
are tense or flaccid,
a pustule is an
elevated circumscribed
purulent fluid-filled lesion
a wheel is an
elevated erythematous
area of dermal edema
this is also referred
to as welts,
hives, or urticaria
here is an example of
a tan macule the cause
of these tan macules
is solar lentigenes
There's also a black macule
with a spiculated border.
We'll come back to
some of these shapes
later on in the lecture.
This is specifically
what we refer to as
an ink spot lentigo,
and these are all on
the posterior neck.
Here are two more
examples of macules.
On the left, we have
depigmented, meaning no pigment,
macules that occur in
vitiligo. On the right,
we have hypopigmented,
or less pigment,
macules that are found
in tinea versicolor.
Here's an example
of a well-demarcated
oval brown patch in
the preauricular area.
Here are some examples
of papules. These
are the classic dome
-shaped umbilicated
papules of Molluscum
contagiosum.
here is a patient with
several dark brown verrucus
papules on the temple
and cheek and around
the eye verrucus is a
term that means wart-like
here is a picture of more
pink or flesh-colored papules
here is an example
of a nodule because
of these nodules
is lymphoma cutis.
Here's another nodule.
This is a pink and dark
brown nodule, and
there is some secondary
scale, and this is found
on the leg. We'll talk
a little bit more about
scale in a little bit.
Here's a close-up of a
thin, violaceous or purplish
crusted plaque on the
forehead. This is from
a superficial pigmented
basal cell carcinoma.
Here's a close-up image of an
ectinic keratosis or an AK.
Ectinic keratosis are often
these thin pink gritty
papules that are often
against a background of
these dermatohelioses or
sun damaged areas of skin.
This picture is from a patient
who has an HSV infection.
These are a clustered
group of tiny vesicles.
Here are some vesicles
and then larger
boule. This is from
linear IgA disease.
Notice how they
have an erythematous
base to them and then
you have the boule
or the vesicles on
top of that base.
Here are some additional
boule. These are bullous
arthropod bites or bug
bites. These are showing
many both tense and
flaccid, meaning that the
boule can be very tense
like it's about to rupture
or flaccid where it's
not quite fully filled.
This is a large
cluster of follicularly
based pustules and
scattered papules.
This comes back to that
question when you ask
about whether it's affecting
a hair bearing area
or not. The difference
in the skin in those hair
bearing areas is that
you will have follicles
and that's where you can
have these more follicular
based patterns like you
see in this picture.
Here are some additional
pustules. This
is a case of erythema
toxicum neonatorum. This is
very common. These are just
tiny pustules on the leg.
This is an image
depicting a welt.
Specifically, this
is dermatographism.
Patients with chronic
urticaria can have this
dermatographism, where
if you agitate the skin,
for example, with a tongue
blade in a very specific
pattern, you will cause
a reaction that leads
to edema in the dermis,
and then the resulting
hive or welt-like picture
that you see here.
Here are some additional
welts that you see
on this image. They're
very large, much more
broad, covering the
majority of the arm
and other aspects of
the chest and shoulder.
Now let's move on to the
secondary skin lesions.
Again, these are
skin lesions that
can evolve from a
primary skin lesion.
can be the result
of an external
force on those skin lesions.
For example, scale is an
accumulation of loose or
adherent, desquamated or
peeling layers of skin.
These are typically keratinized
cells of the stratum corneum.
This often coincides
with dry skin or xerosis.
Xerosis comes from the
Greek word zero meaning dry.
Crust is the dried
remains of fluid
overlying areas
of damaged skin.
This can be blood, pernulant
fluid, or serous fluid.
This comes from the Latin word
crusta meaning rind,
bark, or shell.
An eschar is a specific type of
crust that indicates
skin necrosis.
An erosion is a depression
in the surface of the
skin from the loss of the
superficial epidermis.
An excoriation is a
specific type of erosion
that is caused by
abrasion or scratching.
An ulceration is a
depression in the
surface of the skin
from loss of the
epidermis and some
or all of the dermis.
In contrast to erosions
and ulcers where you have
a loss of the skin layers
you can have atrophy
which is a thinning of skin
layers. If have epidermal
thinning this results
in a fine wrinkling
appearance. If you have
dermal thinning this will
result in a depression in
the surface of the skin.
A fissure is where you
have a linear cleavage or
crack in the skin that
extends into the dermis.
Lichenification is
a thickening of the
epidermis that leads
to a pronunciation
or accentuation of
the skin markings.
A scar is an area
of fibrous tissue
proliferation that
replaces an area of skin
where the dermis
had suffered damage.
A hypertrophic scar is an
elevated scar but it is
still confined to the
original borders of the
tissue damage whereas a
keloid is a scar that is
elevated and spreads beyond
the original borders.
This picture demonstrates
a scaly plaque
that is found in
psoriasis. This is a very
common classic
presentation for psoriasis.
Here's a close-up of a
plaque that is more white and
purple in color and there's
some overlying scale.
Here is an eroded plaque
with purulent crust.
This is a secondary infection
that occurred around the eye.
Here you have the classic honey
-colored crust that
you see in impetigo.
These are primary HSV
lesions on the vaginal
mucosa that shows numerous
erosions on the *****.
Here you have an
erosion with crusting.
Here is a picture of
excoriations. These are those
specific type of erosions
due to scratching or rubbing.
This picture demonstrates
ulcers where you have
a loss of both the
epidermis and the dermis.
You all often have that
white yellowish base.
This is an example of
an ulcerated plaque
with a hemorrhagic
crust on the cheek.
Here's a picture of
ulcers with overlying
eschars, again
that specific type
of crust that indicates
skin necrosis.
Here's an example of a
depressed plaque. So again,
this is a palpable skin
lesion, and so we would
define it as a plaque. This
is an example of atrophy.
Here's another example
of atrophy where
you can see some
hypopigmentation as well.
This is an example of
a fissure where you
can have a linear
cleavage or crack that
you see there in the
middle of the picture.
Here's another example
of some hyperkeratotic
plaques and associated
fissures on the palm.
This is a picture that
demonstrates lichenification.
This is where, again,
you have that thickening
of the epidermis, and you
see that the skin markings
there are much more
obvious and pronounced.
Here is a close-up
of a scaly plaque
that exhibits lichenification.
Here's another example
of lichenification
where you also have
some hyperpigmentation.
Again, a scaly plaque.
This is on the dorsal
hand near the web space
between the fingers.
Here is a close-up of a
raised elevated hypertrophic
scar that has a shiny
appearance again it is
defined within the borders
of the original injury
here's a close-up of a
hyperpigmented keloid so
again where it has spread
beyond the original injury
now let's talk about some
other features of the
primary lesions we can
talk about shape which is
describing an individual
lesion or a configuration which
will describe an arrangement
of multiple lesions.
Now let's go through some
shapes here. An annular
shape is ring-shaped with a
variation in the appearance
between the periphery and
the center of the lesion.
Discoid or nummular
is a circular or coin
shape with a uniform
appearance across the
entirety of the lesion
where there is no
difference between the
periphery and the center.
An ovoid shape is a
shape that is round
with an elliptical
or oval shape,
and again having a
uniform appearance.
Targetoid is ring
-shaped but having two
distinct zones that
vary in appearance.
Another term or
variation is concentric,
meaning a ring inside a ring.
An arcuate is an incomplete
ring or has an arc shape.
Stellate is having
multiple angulated
edges, often resembling a star.
Now let's go through some
examples of these shapes.
Here we have a child with
urticaria, and you see that
they have edematous and
erythematous plaques that
are annular in shape or
ring shape. You can see this
particularly here where
you have an outer, more red
appearance, and then the
inner clearer appearance.
And again, this is what gives
it that classic ring shape.
Here is a child with
urticaria multiforme.
You can see arcuate
-shaped lesions,
annular-shaped lesions,
polycyclic lesions.
These are all plaques
with lighter centers.
here is a nummular lesion
that you would see in
nummular dermatitis as you
can tell they're more uniform
and there is no difference
between the outer
part of the lesion and the
center part of the lesion
here are some atypical
targetoid lesions that you
would see in Stevens-Johnson
syndrome as you can see
it's almost as if you have
a target and there's a
darker red circle in a
bigger lighter red circle.
Here's some more
classic target lesions
where you have even
three zones of color the
outer more red color
followed by a paler
inner ring and then the
more dark red center.
Let's go through some
configurations now. You can
also have an annular
configuration just like you can
have an annular shape. An
annular configuration is
where you have a circular
arrangement of lesions.
A linear configuration,
in addition to
the linear shape, you
can have an arrangement
of lesions forming
a line or a band.
Reticulate configurations
are an arrangement of
lesions that have a net
-like or lacy appearance.
Clustered lesions
are multiple lesions
that are directly
adjacent to each other.
Confluent configuration
is where you have
multiple lesions that
are joining together, so
where you would have
multiple papules or
multiple macules that
are all coming together.
Discrete lesions are distinct,
separate from each other.
Geometric configuration
is where you have distinct
sharp borders with a
pattern that suggests the
lesion was derived by an
object against the skin.
On this patient's face
we see some superficial
erosions that have some
in a linear configuration
especially here where my
cursor is more by his mouth.
Here's a close-up of grouped
and confluent vesicles
that have a thin erythematous
plaque underneath them.
You could also demonstrate
a linear configuration if
you were just to look at
this part of the lesions.
Here are grouped vesicles
that are becoming
confluent and forming
larger bullae. You also
will have the underlying
erythema and then
some other scattered
papules in this image.
Here is a reticulate
red brown erythema on
the legs this is where
again you kind of
have these interwoven
or net or lace-like
configuration of lesions
we have a plaque in
a very distinct shape
this is a very demarcated
border and this is
from a tape that was
applied to this patient's
skin that they had a
reaction to, and so we
would call this a
geometric configuration.
Let's go through patterns.
So when we talk about patterns,
one of the most common
patterns that we'll use
is a dermatomal pattern.
These are lesions that
follow a specific dermatome
of a single spinal
efferent nerve root. These
are unilateral and they
do not cross the midline.
You can have a
gut tape pattern.
This is where the
lesions look as if they
were dropped on the
skin using a dropper.
Serpiganous is where
you have lesions
wandering in an
arrangement or pattern as
though it's following
the track of a snake.
A follicular pattern
is where lesions
are centered around
hair follicles.
Here you have a very
classic example of
shingles where you have
grouped vesicles with
erythema that are in a
T3 dermatomal pattern.
This picture represents
a gut tape pattern where
you have several
discrete well-separated
individual lesions scattered
on this patient's back.
Here you have a serpiganous
erythema. This is
from a jellyfish sting.
You can see that it has
more of a curvy linear
again almost as if a
snake is winding its way
along this patient's arm
here's a close-up of a
follicular pattern so
you have distinct follicular
scaly papules here
here's a more close-up
view of that follicular
pattern this is where you
can clearly see in both of
these papules, or pustules
I mean, a hair that is
arising from the center of
these lesions. So this is
again where you'd have a
follicular-based pustule.
Here you have a patient
where in their web spaces
of their fingers they
have scaly smooth papules.
Now let's shift gears and talk
about how we examine hair.
Hair loss is defined
as effluvium or
defluvium, which means
shedding of hair.
Baldness is the
resulting condition,
and we refer to
this as alopecia.
Alopecia can be
cicatricial, which
is scarring alopecia,
or non-cicatricial,
which is non-scarring alopecia.
The distinguishing
factor here is that in
scarring or cicatricial
alopecia, we would
have an absence of
follicular orifices.
Excess hair growth.
Hirsutism is excess
hair growth in
women in a male
distribution pattern.
Hypertrichosis can occur
in males or females
and is defined as excess
hair growth for age,
race, and *** in a
non-male distribution.
So this is where
you have hair growth
that results in hair
density or length
beyond accepted
limits of normal.
Here is a female patient
with hirsutism. You
can see the hairs on
the upper and lower lip.
This patient has a
large brown plaque
with associated hypertrichosis.
This is a female
that has hirsutism on
the central chest and
around the ******.
Here are some additional
features to look
at when you are examining
a patient's hair.
Is the hair fine or coarse?
Or is there a difference in the
diameter or caliber
of the hair?
Is there thinning or a
decreased density of the hair?
You can assess this by
looking at how much space is
present between parts of
the hair and are there
short or broken hairs that
are really easy to pull
out these are referred to
as exclamation point hairs
a specific couple of
tests here is where
you can do what's
called a hair pull test
this is where you grab 50
to 60 hairs at the base
and you pull firmly if you
pull more than six hairs
this is a positive test
and indicates active hair
loss. You can then evaluate
those extracted hairs
and determine if they are
antigen or telogen hairs.
A trichogram is where you
have 50 hairs and then
you count the number of
antigen and telogen hairs.
You can also perform
trichoscopy which is
using a dermatoscope
to examine the hair.
Here you have a picture of
antigen and telogen hairs
on the left is the antigen
hair you can see towards the
bottom it is a more darker
more malleable curly end
whereas on the telogen these
are also called club hairs
and you can kind of see
the club shape here here's
a close-up of non-scarring
alopecia this is an example
of exclamation point hairs
right in the middle here
is the most distinct one
and you start from the more
distal end where it's much
darker. Going towards the skin
it gets lighter and then
it's almost white and then
you have where it reaches
the skin surface and you
generally have a darker more
round connection to the skin.
And again these are
resembling exclamation points.
Here is a dermatoscopic
image of lichen planopolaris.
The red arrows indicate
more irregularly
distributed follicular openings
and this is representative
of a circuitricial or
a scarring hair loss.
Now let's go through
some common conditions.
Pattern hair loss, for
example male pattern
baldness or androgenic
alopecia, is the
most common type of
progressive hair loss.
Alopecia areata is
localized loss of
hair in round or
oval shaped areas.
Telogen effluvium is
a transient increased
shedding of normal hairs.
Most commonly patients
will present with a
complaint of increased daily
hair loss, especially
with brushing their hair.
Traction alopecia results
from styling of the hair,
where you have an increased
tension or pulling on
parts of the hair. This
can be transient, but if it
is prolonged, it can lead
to a scarring alopecia.
here we have a diffuse
mild thinning of the hair
on the crown or vertex
of the hair you can see
in the midline part there
is much more skin visible
this is an example of
a female patterned or
hair loss or androgenic
alopecia of a female this
is another example again
you see that diffuse
thinning especially over
the crown or vertex of
the head and again widening
of that midline part.
This patient has a
non-scarring alopecia
areata with a distinct
oval or circular shape.
This is where you
see that there's
already some hair regrowth.
Hair loss is not confined
to the scalp you can
also have hair loss in
the beard area as seen in
this picture where again
you have that round patch
of alopecia areata
underneath the patient's chin
here is some decreased
hair density in
the anterior scalp
along the hairline
here is another patient
that exhibits decreased
hair density on the
vertex of their scalp
this patient has a non
-scarring traction alopecia this
is where the original
hairline is more anterior and
because of that traction
the hairline has receded and
you have a decreased hair
density this is also referred
to as a fringe sign this
patient has a pink white
plaque with more focal
scarring alopecia of the scalp.
Now let's shift gears
again and talk about
how we examine nails.
This picture just has
the basic terminology
of the different parts
of the nail so referring
to the cuticle,
the lunilla of the nail plate,
the lateral nail groove,
the lateral nail
fold of the skin.
You're talking about
a patient with a nail
complaint, ask if they've
noticed changes to
the nail color, the
nail surface texture,
how thick the nail is,
is the issue underneath
the nail, which we'd
refer to as subungle.
Chromonychia is a nail
discoloration, so this is where
specific examples would
be a leukonychia, which is
the most common, where you
have a white discoloration.
Melanonychia is another
form of nail discoloration
that refers to a
black discoloration.
Some examples of surface
texture abnormalities
that you'll find is
where you can have
brittle nails, you can
see longitudinal and
transverse grooves, you
can also see pitting.
So brittle nails
we will see what's
referred to as onychorexis
which is a distal
longitudinal
splitting of the nail.
You can also see onychoschisia,
which is a horizontal
or lamellar splitting
at the nails free end.
Nail pitting is
where you have small
depressions in the nail surface
resulting from abnormal
keratinization.
Tracheonychia is the term
that describes rough nails.
Onycholysis is when
you have detachment
of the nail from
the distal nail bed.
Here you have a patient
with onychoschizia.
This patient has
coarse pitting of the
nails and then some
distal onycholysis.
This patient has trachonychia.
This patient also
has alopecia areata.
Here's another picture of more
roughened, discolored
nail plates.
I just wanted to make
a few last comments on
melanoma. Obviously, you're
going to get a much more
in-depth lecture on
melanoma and the other skin
cancers, but I just wanted
to talk about how do
we assess a patient's
risk factors for melanoma.
One way to remember
these is the HARM
mnemonic on the left.
This stands for a
history of previous
melanoma, age over 50,
regular dermatologist absent,
mole changing, and male gender.
So the R just means
that you're not
seeing a dermatologist
on a regular basis.
The first M just means that you
have a mole that is changing.
Other risk factors
are if you have 50 or
more common moles,
if you have red or a
lighter hair color, and
a lighter eye color.
Freckles are a risk factor.
If you have increased
sun exposure, obviously
in UV radiation
from tanning booths,
immunosuppression, and if
you have a family history.
Next, how do we assess
for features that
would be concerning
for melanoma? These are
often referred to as
the ABCDEs of melanoma.
You would assess for the
asymmetry where comparing
one side to the other
there is a difference,
if there's borders that
are irregular that could be
notched, ragged, or blurred,
if you have a color change
especially blue or black
or a darker coloration,
if the diameter is greater
than six millimeters,
and then if you just have
any evolution or change
in the size, symptoms, and
morphology of a lesion.
This is a diagram that
just has a different
representation of
those ABCDEs and
gives you a few examples
of each of those.
Alright, I know that
that was a lot of slides
with all those pictures
added. I did post two separate
PowerPoint files on
Canvas, one that has the
pictures included and
one without the pictures.